all right um we're going to break in
with this Fox News Alert here we have
just gotten word former president Donald
Trump has been indicted by a grand jury
in New York Trump was under
investigation by the DA's office for his
alleged hush money payment to adult film
star Stormy Daniels during the 2016
campaign so as we await more information
Fox News has just learned this from two
law enforcement sources that Trump has
been indicted
perhaps I can go around the table Katie
I'll start with you first
well the president said two weeks ago
that this was going to happen eventually
he thought it would happen uh last
Tuesday the grand jury then did not
convene for two days in a row
um and the grand jury was out of town
allegedly for a month as of yesterday so
this is quite interesting
um to hear after they were sent home for
the for the month now leading up to this
there was a lot of talk about whether
this would even happen considering Alvin
Bragg who was the Manhattan district
attorney who was looking into bringing
these charges would be able to just
given how long it's been since these
this incident and it was allegedly a
misdemeanor charge it's never been
happened in the history of the New York
attorney's office before and there's
been a lot of controversy about whether
it was appropriate given the president
is a presidential candidate again and
whether it was politically motivated as
a result of this district attorney not
having the authority to bring it also of
course there are big questions about the
District Attorney's priority when it
comes to his uh
obligations in New York to put hardened
criminals who are carrying out very
violent crimes in the city Behind Bars
when now he is focused on President
Trump but here we are with this the
president said it was going to happen so
now there are big questions about how
this will go down whether the president
will come to New York to be
fingerprinted uh to to take the charges
in person and what that will look like
with secret service and NYPD and whether
there will be a mug shot and how that
will be handled I think that's important
to ask at this point Jesse we don't
exactly know how this will go down but
we do know that the indictment would not
be announced until it was stamped to the
DA's office would then notify an
attorney for the former president that
he would then be indicted at that point
the president is then free to make the
information public himself we are
reporting this as we've learned it from
two law enforcement officials we'll see
if we hear anything from the former
president uh as the the moments go on
here will he be arrested would there be
any sort of mug shot taken will he
appear in court those are questions that
we do not have answers to at this moment
it's the stupidest thing I've ever seen
and I feel bad for the guy he didn't
even really have to be president he had
a lot of money he had a great life and
he decided to run he won he got in they
took him down
and now they're trying to nickel and
dime them for a private agreement he
made with a woman what eight years ago
it has nothing to do with politics
wasn't paid with through campaign funds
this is a disgrace and I think it takes
about a week to get the logistics in so
he'll come up and he will get
fingerprinted and they'll get a mug shot
and then they'll plaster that mug shot
all over the country for the next two
years and run against a criminal and
that's what this is all about no one
wanted this not even the left wanted
this
but now I'm thinking Brad got
embarrassed because everything you heard
over the last 48 hours is they were just
going to put this to bed and take a
break for a month
so I don't know if there's pressure put
on him because his numbers went up in
the last couple weeks when this thing
swirled so maybe the left's calculating
that indicting this guy is going to get
him the nomination and they think he's
easier to be
but I wouldn't be so sure about that
because there's going to be a major
rally around the flag feeling I'm
starting to feel it right now I'm angry
about it I don't like it country's not
going to stand for it
and people better be careful and that's
all I'll say about that okay this is the
third Act of the movie right it really
is this is how it has to be that
guarantees his nomination Alvin Bragg is
the amalga Republican of the year he
just got Trump's nomination I think if
there's a mug shot which there will be
you gotta own it that's got to be the
poster that's got to be he's he is an OG
right if they give me I mean he is a
badass if he's got a mug shot you might
as well go right into it and the thing
is I I you know his poll numbers have
gone up with this I just think this is
good good to make sure he he is gonna be
on the ticket and to your point they
made that gamble in 2016 they thought
that he would lose to Hillary and he
didn't so I don't I I don't know if they
really think that this is good like the
The Joy Behar logic which is like Oh
They'll be easy to beat just one factual
point it's being reported that it's a
felony indictment that I was saying
earlier that they were looking at it as
a misdemeanor and that's why much of the
the criticism was about that issue there
was talk to Alvin Bragg as the Manhattan
district attorney would try to make it a
felony to make it a more serious charge
and now of course he's going to have to
prove this because he's the one who's
taking the information from the grand
jury and he will have to then explain
why Beyond a reasonable doubt he thinks
that the charges will stick Jessica he
did he was bumping it up because it was
seen as something to help Donald Trump's
campaign because this all happened a
couple of weeks before the election so
clearly was something that he didn't
want to come out
and inform the results of the 2016
election
I'm completely shocked buy this when
Trump said I'm going to be indicted on
Tuesday I thought okay maybe it's not
Tuesday but this is coming then
everything that was leaking out from the
grand jury or they weren't meeting on
their normal days and then the letter
that Alvin Bragg sent back in response
to the House GOP committee and said
basically this is all your invention
you're the ones that are talking about
an indictment no one out of New York is
talking about it and I thought that that
was due to the fact that there was a lot
of pressure on him from liberals I
talked about it on air saying that of
all of the Myriad of things that Donald
Trump is under investigation for this is
not the one where you're going to be
able to Rally people around to say yeah
this is unequivocally a thing that he
did wrong it was going to be what
happened in Georgia was with pressuring
officials there to overturn the 2020
election which there is no evidence but
go ahead phone calls saying find me
what's your definition of find like do
you find something that you have to
create or do you find something that's
already there
it had been certified
good masseuse I don't say create a new
masseuse find me a masseuse you don't
think that the tour of Donald Trump and
all of his lawyers throughout the
country trying to get the results
overturned in States like Arizona and
Pennsylvania I was just responding to
Georgia okay so anyway Georgia was on
your mind
the mug shot will definitely be part of
this I mean Donald Trump was up the Fox
News poll that just came up he's up 30
points in this and he was going to be
the nominee anyway I mean he was even
talking about should Ron DeSantis run
this time around he's young wait until
Trump is out of the picture if you're
going to do this um but it certainly
looks like he would be the number this
is a moment in American history that
people will remember this is a political
Rubicon that has been crossed uh it will
bring it will certainly change the GOP
Primary but it will also change
precedent and Democrats talk a lot about
precedent well they just set one with
this yeah
and by the way since this is White
Collar we obviously have our camera
outside the DA's office here in New York
um the DA's office has to now ask
Trump's attorney when he plans to come
to New York to to be arraigned uh it
doesn't require him to turn himself in
so there's no specific time frame it
could be any minute now it could be any
day but we'll see well you can zoom it
in but they won't let them Zoom it in
because they want the spectacle he wants
it too though he doesn't want to be
indicted if you think he wants this he
doesn't want it the family doesn't want
it
imagine being Barron Trump hey Dad what
are you looking at it's not good and
it's horrible that Alvin Bragg who's a
joke in this town
who should get run out of town because
crimes running wild is going after this
if you get a haircut
a couple weeks before an election and
you pay for it out of your own pocket
not campaign funds how is that a
campaign Finance felony
you were going to get a haircut anyway
you wanted to look good anyway just like
he would have paid off this woman anyway
is the same as getting a touch up on
your hair it's PR and it's called a
great analogy I just want to get this in
here as well per our Chad program on
Capitol Hill
um the fox has spoken with one senior
aide and one source close to the house
inquiry of Manhattan D.A Alvin Alvin
Bragg they were said that they received
no heads up about the indictment uh
we're hearing about this and digesting
in real time is what Chad is reporting
from Capitol Hill at this hour hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else